one of the women accusing new york
governor andrew cuomo of sexual
harassment
is speaking on camera for the first time
charlotte bennett spoke exclusively to
cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell
she describes deeply uncomfortable
conversations with the governor
in which she says it became clear to her
that he was trying to sleep with her
governor cuomo faces an inquiry and
calls to resign over this along with
allegations from two additional women
and other controversies
he has apologized for the behavior that
he says was unintentional
but he also says he will not step down
for more on all this let's bring in nora
o'donnell from washington nora good
morning to you this was a very frank
very direct interview
it really was good morning tony you know
a lifelong new yorker charlotte bennett
began working as an entry-level
assistant to governor andrew cuomo in
january 2019.
she called it a dream job when cuomo
became a celebrity for his handling of
the pandemic
bennett says the attention emboldened
him and she alleges he began
sexually harassing her looking back on
all of this
how would you describe governor cuomo he
is
a textbook abuser he
lets his temper and his anger rule the
office
but he was very sweet to me for a year
in the hopes that maybe one day
when he came on to me i would think
we were friends or that it was
appropriate or that it was okay
bennett says their professional
relationship took a turn on may 15th
when she alleges the governor started
asking her about her love life
and became fixated repeating over and
over again her history
as a sexual assault survivor so he goes
you were raped you were raped
you were raped and abused and assaulted
why do you think he was fixated
on you as a survivor of sexual assault
i think it's really
strategic i think abusers
look for vulnerabilities previous
traumas
the idea that maybe i'm more willing
to accept behavior because i have
a history of sexual violence
perhaps i'm not as confident in myself
because of my history you think he knew
that
yeah you think he was grooming you yeah
and bennett says on june 5th governor
cuomo crossed a line
he wanted a girlfriend when he said he
was lonely i mentioned that his
daughters had been around
and he also rejected that and said
yeah love my i love my daughters but
that's
i want a girlfriend bennett says he
asked whether she'd ever been with an
older man
what were you thinking as he's asking
you
these questions i thought he's trying to
sleep with me
the governor is trying to sleep with me
and
i'm deeply uncomfortable
and i have to get out of this room as
soon as possible and to be clear
what made you think that he was trying
to sleep with you without explicitly
saying it
he he implied
to me that i was old enough for him and
he was lonely
as you left work on june 5th
what were you thinking
i was trying not to cry i assumed
that i could no longer work for him i
gotta get out of this job
i'm not doing that again i'm not
engaging in that conversation or any
other conversation
i'm not putting myself in a position
where he physically comes onto me
it stops here that's it
but then you get called back into the
office the next day
saturday june 6th and you've never
talked about this before
no bennett says at one point on that
saturday
she was the only employee working with
the governor in his private office
i was terrified i was shaking
i i thought any moment something can
happen
and i have no power here and what
happens when you're with the governor
he asked me a few questions about how to
use his iphone
and then sends me back to wait and then
finally he calls me in and he
asks if i found him a girlfriend yet
he asked you again yes i say not yet
i said i was working on it governor
cuomo said in a statement
on sunday that he was just being playful
was it playful no
he says he was joking i wasn't laughing
and he wasn't laughing how do you
respond to viewers who may doubt your
story
it's hard enough sharing this story
when it's true i can't imagine what it
would be like to sit here
and tell you lies i don't know
who would do that i i couldn't make this
up
and also i loved my job like i really
looked up to him
i looked up to the governor he was my
mentor i really did see it that way
well we reached out to the governor
cuomo's office to respond to charlotte
bennett's claims and they directed us to
the governor's apology on wednesday
where he said he never knew
at the time that he was making anyone
uncomfortable he asked people to wait
for the results of the state attorney
general's investigation
and we'll have more news from our
interview with bennett that's going to
be tonight on the cbs evening news
nora this is just a devastating
interview does charlotte bennett
think the governor should face
consequences
you know it's interesting she said that
she wants the governor to start telling
the truth
she says if the investigation finds that
he conducted himself in an inappropriate
way
then he should step down and then in
perhaps some grace
she says that he does have the ability
to rehabilitate himself and do the
emotional work necessary to become a
better person
but we've also seen what she calls this
corroborating evidence these are
text messages that she sent to friends
at the time that describe her state of
mind after those encounters
the governor isn't just facing sexual
harassment allegations new this morning
the wall street journal and the new york
times
are both reporting some of cuomo's top
aides altered a july 2020 report
to under count the number of nursing
home residents who died of covid
the report that was released to the
public was under counted by thousands of
deaths nor why is this
significant well i think it's
significant because
governor cuomo is from a storied
political family he wrote a book on
leadership
lessons he was praised for his handling
of the code crisis
now we're learning what was happening
behind the scenes
the allegations from charlotte bennett
the allegations in the investigation
centered on
on what are the efforts to obscure the
number of nursing home
deaths and so all of this now we're just
getting a glimpse
of really as they pull back the curtain
the reporting in the investigation
what was really happening behind the
scenes all right nora thank you and as
norah said you can see more of her
interviews tonight on the cbs
evening news thank you tony